alors on passe tout de suite la parole à
la salle vous avez la parole pour
interpeller sur le projet nos
secrétaires nationaux ceux qui ont
délibéré qui ont travaillé sur le projet
vous avez à la tribune George fenec
notre spécialiste de justice Vous avez
Philippe Meunier qui s'occupe des
questions de défense vous avez Françoise
groset sur l'Europe vous avez pierre
lelouge sur les affaires internationales
au sens large on va dire mon cher Pierre
alors la parole micro
rouge vous présenter s'il vous plaît
et j'ai la lourde tâche de régler
l'horloge donc pour plus vous ferez
court plus vous serez nombreux à parler
promis Christine bonfantiossat maire
conseiller départemental et SD du
lotégaron tout d'abord permettez-moi de
vous remercier de nous avoir permis de
participer à l'élaboration de ce projet
d'être les acteurs majeurs de ce
rendez-vous ce travail on l'a dit tout à
l'heure et le résultat de nombreuses
conventions thématiques organisées par
notre secrétaire général que je remercie
j'aborderai si vous le permettez très
rapidement le thème de la sécurité euh
si nous faisons une comparaison de la
situation de mai 2012 à août 2015 on se
rend compte que tous les indicateurs
sont à la hausse l'exgarde des saut
Christian tobira dont on ne compte plus
les exploits euh n'a pas souhaitait
s'engager dans un plan de construction
de place de prison et ce malgré la
surpopulation carcérale et les
100000 prisons fermes qui en attente
d'exécution
aujourd'hui l'actualité la rattrape
puisque la prison de Florie muringis est
est en en conflit et l'actualité est
parlante elle a contre toute attente au
contraire introduit la contrainte pénale
la contrainte pénale c'est ainsi que des
délinquants qui ont des peines courtes
entre 6 mois et 5 ans ne vont plus en
prison les Français n'admettent plus
qu'une peine de
prison pour l'État fait par le peuple
français ne soit plus respecté alors
aujourd'hui ma question est de dire
comment mettre
fin à cette forme d'hypocrisie qui
légitime qui
légitime d'une manière trop
importanteénement pe exécution des pees
comment régler notre problème politique
pénale exécution des pees comment régler
notre problème de
capacité de de capacité carcérale voilà
merci merci Christine je vais demander à
George notre spécialiste des questions
de justice de de répondre peut-être il y
a une question au micro TR bleu mais
vraiment vous faites très court très
court s'il vous plaît de pour être sûr
là une question
peut-être je sais pas non bon allez
George à toi pour répondre à Christine
bon je vais répondre à Christine mais
Christine a déjà fait les réponse à sa
question elle a apporté déjà beaucoup
d'éléments je rejoins vraiment toutes
ces préoccupations et les critiques
qu'elle vient de formuler que
voulez-vous que je vous dise tout ce que
nous avions fait avant
sous le péché originel du précédent
quinquena et donc Madame tobira
effectivement dès son arrivée a supprimé
les pin planché a fait supprimer un peu
plus tard les tribunaux correctionnels
pour mineurs a abandonné le programme de
construction des 28 places de prison qui
font aujourd'hui cruellement défaut
surtout qu'on cherche à créer des
quartiers dédiés pour les terroristes et
donc des incellulements individuel ce
qui complique énormément la tâche donc
nous sommes dans une situation où vous
l'avez dit la délinquance a explosé il y
a 75 % des Français qui n'ont plus
confiance en leur institution judiciire
aujourd'hui vous avez raison de
souligner qu'il y a quelques 100000
peines de prison qui sont en attente
d'exécution et pendant ce temps-là
évidemment ça fait le bonheur de la
délinquence d'habitude et de la
délinquence des récidivistes donc il va
falloir cher président va falloir
reconstruire cette institution
judiciaire lui redonner son autorité
mais également aussi et j'en termine par
là faire en sorte que cette justice elle
fonctionne de manière indépendante et
dépolitisée et je voudrais à cet égard
qu'il me soit permis quand même de
rendre hommage à ce qui s'est fait sous
le précédent quinquena on a tort de ne
pas le rappeler assez souvent qui avait
fait la réforme du Conseil supérieur
d'administrature pour plus
d'indépendance en 2008 qui avait créé
par exemple les questions prioritaires
de de constitutionnalité qui avait créé
le contrôleur général des lieux de
privation de liberté et cetera et cetera
et cetera donc aujourd'hui voyez-vous on
n pas à rougir de ce que nous avions
fait avant par contre on peut vraiment
s'inquiéter de la destruction de la
déconstruction du système répressif
judiciaire il va falloir rebâtir
entièrement en lui donnant aussi les
moyens budgétaires souvenez-vous
monsieuras a déclaré que la justice
était en état de clochardisation donc
voyez un vaste programme qui nous attend
qui est inclus dans notre programme des
républicains et que nous mett en uvre
merci
George Nicolas
oui en complément de ce que vient très
bien dire George il y a une idée fausse
une de plus qui est l'idée de la pensée
unique selon laquelle il y aurait en
France trop de gens en prison c'est faux
si on compare la France avec toutes les
autres démocraties
occidentales nous sommes le pays où il y
a le moins de délinquants en prison la
deè remarque c'est que le nombre de
prisons le nombre de plac de prison de
notre point de vue et fonction du nombre
de
délinquants avec madameb Monsieur c'est
le contraire on adapte le nombre de
délinquants au nom de plac de prison
disponible nous nous vouons le nombre de
plac de prison au délinquants qui
doivent se retrouver en prison pour
arrêter d'empoisonner la vie des
citoyens et des jeun gens et
troisièmement George pardon parce que je
sais que
c'était ça a été un fameux débat y
compris lorsqu'on était au
gouvernement j'avais voulu que les
Français siège dans les tribunaux
correctionnels non pas tu t'en souviens
pour les petites peines naturellement
mais pour les peines au-delà de 5 ans
nous avions fait une réforme pour qu'il
y ait des jurés populaires dans les
tribunaux correctionnel pour que la
justice soit rendue au nom du peuple
français et pas au nom d'une idéologie
dominante et d'une pensée unique qui
veut culpabiliser la majorité contre une
minorité de délinquants dont on ne veut
plus la présence des Français dans les
juris de tribunaux correctionnels nous
la remettrons en œuvre parce que la
justice doit être rendu au nom du peuple
français voilà la la réalité des
changements que nous proposons je vous
remercie
excuse-moi merci nous prenons une
question micro bleu alors bonjour à tous
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs Sonia Péro présidente de la
Fédération de la Guadeloupe la
Guadeloupe est devenue ces dernières
années l'un des départements où les
chiffres de la criminalité et de la
délinquence ont le plus augmenté
malheureusement sur le terrain dès qu'on
en parle nous de droite on nous répond
que c'est sous le dernier quinquena que
les chiffres de la de la police de
proximité ont le plus baissé alors ma
question est la suivante comment mettre
en œuvre en Guadeloupe et dans d'autres
départements le principe d'égalité de
tous les citoyens de bénéficier de la
même sécurité des biens et des personnes
on a le sentiment que nos départements
sont devenus des variables d'ajustement
de la politique budgétaire d'austérité
du point de vue des effectifs de police
merci merci
Sonia alors George tu veux redire un mot
sur j'y suis tellement attaché à ces
départements j'ai été moi-même procureur
à pointapitre il y a bien longtemps et
je connais la misère de ces départements
d'outremer que ce soit en terme de de
lieu de détention en terme de d'effectif
de police qu'il y a une délinquence
galopante nous sommes vraiment à la
traain et je je crois que vous avez tout
à fait raison Madame il va falloir
établir au nom de l'égalité les mêmes
moyens dans les départements d'outrem
que sur le territoire
métropolitain merci George bris stefeu
notre ancien ministre de l'Intérieur
juste un mot qui permet de rétablir
aussi une vérité vous l'avez entendu les
uns et les autres c'est vrai pour les
territoires d'outremè mais ça été vrai
aussi pour la métropole on a entendu
depuis 2 3 ans le débat sur les
effectifs et la dégr de la délinquence
qui est enregistrée dans tous les
domaines depuis 2012
2002-22 baisse des violences au personne
baisse de la délinquence économique
baisse des violences physiques baisse
des atteintes aux bien tout ceci depuis
2012 s'est inversé et il y avait une
responsabilité et une seule c'était
celle des effectifs mettons de côté ce
qu'on coûtait les 35 he à la police et à
la gendarmerie comme ailleurs
c'est-à-dire l'équivalent de 8000 postes
mais il y a quelques jours à peine a été
rendu publ une analyse très intéressante
de la Cour des comptes que d'ailleurs
Olivier marlex avait découvert cette
analyse de la Cour des comptes montre la
chose suivante au-delà des mots au-delà
des postures au-delà des coup de mon
au-delà des annonces de recrutement
jusqu'à 9000 policiers le chiffre à 3
prês est resté exactement le
même depuis 2012 ça n'a quasiment pas
bougé ni pour la police ni pour la
gendarmerie donc la réalité c'est cela
entre 2002 et 2002 sous l'autorité
notamment de Nicolas SAR la délinquence
a baiss depuis 2012 effectif en réalité
constant celleciugment sur tous les
sujs parole à Roger carucci notre
secrétaire général adjoint chargé des
élections qui a été beaucoup mis à
contribution ces dernières semaines avec
le travail sur la préparation des
législatives Roger c'est à toi merci
merci lu mais je rassure tout le monde
nous ne parlerons des investitures
qu'après les élections primaires donc
c'est pas mon sujet du jour en revanche
moi je voulais vous dire de mots sur
l'actuel président de la
République
j'ai encore rien
dit l'actuel président de la République
paraît-il est pressé de venir
s'expliquer devant les Français il
paraît qu'il veut débattre il paraît
qu'il veut dire des choses et quand on
regarde la réalité on se dit que depuis
4 ans quand même à force de radio à
force de télévision pourquoi veut-il
venir
s'expliquer ça fait 4 ans qu'il dit les
mêmes choses ça fait 4 ans qu'il affirme
les mêmes choses il y a 3 ans il voyait
l'inversion de la courbe du chômage il y
a 2 ans il voyait la croissance
maintenant ça va mieux ça va nettement
mieux pour lui on sait pas si j'en crois
les sondages pas vraiment mais quand on
regarde les résultats 700000 chômeur de
plus en un an malgré les radiations
massives malgré les manipulations quand
on écoute la Cour des comptes cher
Gérard la Cour des comptes vient au
Sénat et nous dit bah tous les chiffres
des déficits de la dette sont faux
évidemment on est beaucoup plus en
déficit beaucoup plus endetté que ce que
l'on dit depuis le début de cette année
le candidat
Hollande a promis 7 milliards d'euros en
plus des dépenses des engagement pour
les fonctionnaires pour les jeunes alors
attention des engagements à partir de
2018 à partir de 2019 à partir de la fin
2017 c'est demain on gratis mais on sait
pas avec quel
pognon Hollande ment au français depuis
la campagne de 2012 Hollande ne dit pas
la vérité aux Français depuis qu'il est
président de la République il vit dans
son monde il exerce dans son monde et
nous nous vivons dans le
quotidien nous nous voyons cher Georg
les forces de sécurité épuisé les forces
de sécurité exaspérées de nuit debout à
l'état
d'urgence de l'ensemble des
manifestations qui n'en finissent plus
au casseur nous avons des forces de
sécurité qui n'y arrive plus et nous
avons un gouvernement qui n'a plus
d'autorité et le vrai enjeu cher Nicolas
le vrai enjeu de la campagne de 2017
au-delà de l'échec en matière financière
au-delà de l'échec en matière économique
au-delà de l'échec en matière fiscale
au-delà de l'échec en matière d'emploi
au-delà de l'échec qui a conduit et nos
jeunes et nos entreprises à quitter le
pays et quand je vois d'ailleurs les
autorités françaises penser que le
brexit ramènerait en France des
entreprises naturellement que non
comment voulez-vous que des entreprises
reviennent avec la fiscalité française
s'installere en France elles iront en
Allemagne elles iront au Pays-Bas elles
iront en Belgique elles ne viendront
évidemment pas en France subir le 75 %
de Monsieur Hollande la fiscalité
démande de Monsieur sapin vraiment non
mais en revanche le vrai débat
c'est l'état c'est l'autorité de l'État
c'est l'identité de ce pays tous les
jours nous avons la
démonstration qu'il n'y a plus
d'autorité non seulement au travers de
l'insécurité mais au travers de la
parole de l'État l'état
négocie l'état discute avec les
syndicats l'état discute avec les
organisations le résultat est absolument
nul la loi travail qui est un BR faire
entre un gouvernement discrédité et des
syndicats où il y a plus personne la loi
travail bientôt il restera que le titre
ce sera la loi et le comerie on sait
plus ce qu'il y aura dedans ils ont fait
des concessions n plus finir et pourtant
ils n'y arrivent pas et les
manifestations se poursuivent et en vrai
nous avons un vrai problème qui est
simple les Français ne se reconnaissent
plus dans l'état actuel les Français ne
se reconnaissent plus dans l'autorité
les Français ne se reconnaissent plus
dans ce qui est leur identité et demain
le Desbat Nicolas ce sera de dire voilà
ah ce sera de dire qu'est-ce que l'État
qu'est-ce que les Français veulent ils
attendent une autorité ils attendent que
naturellement il y ait une force dans la
volonté de l'État il faut qu'il y ait
moins d'incivilité moins d'insécurité
moins de remise en cause plus de fierté
nationale la fierté nationale ça n'est
pas que le drapeau c'est aussi le passé
la tradition la réalité c'est aussi le
fait que ce p pays appartient à une
coutume européenne à une force
européenne c'est aussi le fait de
défendre la France et quand on voit où
on en est pardon Monsieur Hollande mais
quand Nicolas Sarkozi parlait à Poutine
pour régler le problème militaire en
Géorgie vous au début de votre mandat
vous parliez à leonarda on n peut-être
quand même pas sur le même niveau et ça
il faut restaurer l'état quand on voit
aujourd'hui la politique en matière
migratoire quand on voit la politique en
matière d'identité et bien les Français
doutent les Français sont inquiets les
Français ne se projettent plus les
Français ont le sentiment de ne plus
avoir un destin commun et j'arrêterai là
puisque j'ai un temps très bref je vous
dis seulement que le projet
d'aujourd'hui la campagne présidentielle
de demain monsieur le Président elle se
fera autour d'un seul thème restaurer la
fierté des Français restaurer la
confiance des Français dans la France
restaurer l'état et la
République merci Roger je veux saluer la
présence de nos amis parlementaires et
ancien ministre Michel aliomarie David
Douillet Annie jeunevard Claude Greff
parlementaire européen angélique de lae
j'ai aperçu Alain lamassour Guillaume
larrivé Yv Albarello Sébastien hig tous
les parlementaires je vais en oublier
Pierre Frogier Patrick olier qui sont
venus parfois de loin mon cher Pierre en
tout cas merci d'être parmi nous on
reprend la parole à la salle micro bleu
oui monsieur le Président bonjour
mesdames et messieurs bonjour je suis
David Labiche SDA de la Charente
Maritime délégué de la 2e
circonscription et maire adjoint à
Châtel Avon plage une question sur le
terrorisme si vous permettez nous avons
tous souffert je vais le lire
excusez-moi je l'ai préparé sur le train
en venant mais ça me trottait vraiment
de de la poser nous avons tous souffert
nous restons meurtrri et ému par les
attentats répétitions sur notre sol
français comment peut-on lutter
efficacement contre les départs en Syrie
mais surtout mais surtout les retours
des jeunes islamistes radicalisés et
éviter qu'il ne frappe sur notre sol
français petite suggestion pour être
efficace les musulmans dans les mosquées
ne pourrait-il pas
renforcer leur contrôle contre les
prêcheurs radicalisés et collaborer
encore plus avec la justice
française l'État et je l'espère le futur
gouvernement de droite auront-ils les
moyens de régler ces deux points et je
pense que la France ne doit rien céder
sur sa devise Liberté Égalité Fraternité
merci pour votre réponse merci merci
David euh je propose que Philippe
Meunier te réponde
merci euh c'est une question qui est
très vaste et très large qui dépasse
bien entendu une les compétences de nos
forces armées puisquelle relève aussi de
la justice et des forces de sécurité
intérieure ce que j'aimerais simplement
dire c'est que le terrorisme on le
combat à l'extérieur et on le combat à
l'intérieur à l'extérieur à travers nos
opérations extérieures et à l'intérieur
à travers l'opération à
Sentinel il va falloir procéder un
certain nombre de modifications
d'ailleurs pour être plus efficace
notamment sur l'opération sentinelle qui
a montré son inefficacité j'ai à côté de
moi George fen qui préside la commission
d'enquête sur les attentats de 2015 j'ai
écouté les auditions et elles sont très
révélatrices nos forces armées notamment
sentinelles étaient présentes au
Bataclan mais elles n'ont pas pu faire
usage de leurs armes parce qu'elle n'en
avent pas les ordres c'est extrêmement
grave c'est la raison pour laquelle il
va falloir revoir ce dispositif pour
améliorer la sécurité de nos
compatriotes maintenant concernant ceux
qui partent faire le djihad à l'étranger
moi j'ai déposé une proposition de loi
pour les déchoirs de la nationalité
française pour qu'il ne reviennent plus
sur notre territoire national parce que
sont plus des
Français merci Philippe je vais proposer
à David douill de nous rejoindre et de
nous dire un
[Applaudissements]
mot pendant que David se prépare qu'
réajuste les
micro traviller dans la commission
d'enquête sur les terroristes la
question qui vient d'être posée elle est
fondamentale il y a au moins 1500
français en ce moment en Syrie en Irak
et plusieurs centaines de jeunes parfois
des enfants ces gens à mesure que nous
gagnons la guerre à raka et à Mossou
vont revenir en France la question qui
se pose c'est qu'est-ce qu'on en fait
pour l'instant s'il y a pas de
judiciarisation re dit si on n pas la
preuve que ces gens-là parce qu'ils ont
posté des trucs sur internet ont
participé direct des opérations de
guerre on ne peut pas les arrêter donc
ils sont enenvoyés dans leur foyer et il
touchent les
alo il faut absolument qu'on arrive à
créer des systèmes de rétention pour
tous ceux qui reviennent des théâes de
guerre le temps d'examiner leur
situation mais il faut pas qu'il
retourne en liberté donc ça c'est le
grand c'est le grand trou dans la
raquette qui existe aujourd'hui et vous
faites bien la question pardon Luc mais
je voulais le dire parce que ça c'est
une des priorités au moment de
l'alternance nous aurons à gérer ces
gens qui reviennent du djihad merci
Pierre David Douillet merci
Luc moi ce matin comme Roger on a à peu
près 5 minutes pour vous dire ce qu'on
pense on pas beaucoup en tout cas moi
j'ai envie de vous dire une seule chose
que je suis
heureux parmi tout c tout ce marasme
tout ce négatif tout ce qui nous tire
vers le bas l'état actuel de la France
je crois qu'aujourd'hui au regard de ce
qui nous attend c'estàdire des objectifs
qui nous attendent il faut il faut être
positif il faut être heureux il faut que
chacune et chacun d'entre nous rayonne
ça parce que on doit le communiquer à
toutes celles et tous ceux qui devront
nous faire confiance et faire confiance
au candidats pour la présidentielle
c'est extrêmement
important je vous assure que c'est
vrai cette propagation du positif doit
se faire ça doit même devenir un rythme
à partir de maintenant pourquoi on doit
être heureux aujourd'hui tout simplement
parce que notre famille existe elle est
forte et elle est bien là aujour
d'aujourd'hui rappelez-vous l'État dans
laquelle nous étions il y a 2 ans
aujourd'hui nous avons un président des
républicains qui a restructuré le
parti qui l'a désendetté en cours de
désendettement n'est-ce pas
Daniel qui a réussi et c'était pas mince
comme objectif à rassembler chacune et
chacun d'entre nous par rapport au au
déchirement qui s'était occasionné vous
vous souvenez et
puis la sererise sol le gâteau et c'est
la raison pour laquelle on est lâche
aujourd'hui a été capable de mettre en
route et de concevoir et de concevoir un
projet un beau projet une colonne
vertébrale qui devrait toutes et tous
nous amener je l'espère de tout cœur
vers la victoire
avant il va se passer une
chose une chose qui ne doit pas non plus
nous tirer vers le
bas parce que le chemin est encore
long nous sommes globalement à un an des
présidentielles en politique c'est une
éternité en vérité une éternité dans
laquelle nous pouvons encore
chuter et sans être négatif pour le coup
je voudrais juste faire un petite
comparaison avec ce que j'ai bien connu
dans une première vie qu'elle monte de
la compétition elle monte de la
préparation à la compétition parce qu'il
s'agit bien de ça les présidentiell sont
une compétition les primaires ce n'est
que
l'entraînement pendant la primaire nous
aurons des partenaires des partenaires
qui vont s'étalonner les un aux autres
je vous avoue que moi-même la primaire
j'étais pas un fervant convaincu elle
est là elle existe on fait avec cette
primaire en réalité pour la positiver va
nous
servir à ce que nos champions nos futurs
champions puissent se construire
s'étalonner dans une émulation grandir
ensemble avec du
respect
avec une identité extrêmement marquée la
nôtre une colonne vertébrale du projet
qu'on a aujourd'hui mais surtout un
profond respect parce que c'est là notre
talon d'achile s'il n'y a pas cette
entente et cette prospérité mutuelle
nous pouvons chuter on est attendu par
les médias par tous ceux qui n qui ne
nous veulent pas au pouvoir on est
clairement attendu et notre talent
d'Achile aujourd'hui est bien marqué
bien marqué par quelques petits mots
quelques petites phrases dans lesquelles
nous ne devouvons pas tomber
au contraire chacune et chacun d'entre
nous devons bonifier nos prétendants
devons n'expliquer que leur grandes
qualités parce que ils ont des grandes
qualités certains d'entre eux ont été de
grand ou de grandes femmes d'État voilà
ce qui est la vérité et que au lendemain
de ces primaires tout le monde devra
travailler ensemble et ça c'est le plus
important ensemble pourquoi pour gagner
présidenti ensemble
pourquoi en réalité
ensemble
pourquoi pour gagner et ça il ne faut
pas se tromper non plus une étape la
présidentielle en réalité n'est qu'une
étape n nous trompons pas d'objectif
souvent nous avons vu dans le
passé des présidents de de la République
considérer que l'objectif de leur vie
était de devenir président de la
République qu'est-ce qui se passe une
fois qu'on l'IT on gère on s'arrête on
avavance plus je suis sûr que d'ors et
déjà ceux qui ne sont pas encore
candidat à la primaire ou ceux qui le
sont déjà ont déjà compris que la
présidentielle n'est qu'une étape dans
ce parcours et que le véritable objectif
c'est de remettre la France sur les
rails pour les 50 prochaines années ça
c'est le vrai objectif c'est l'objectif
des républicains et ça nous pourrons le
faire qu'ensemble en sur chacun d'entre
vous merci mon ch
Dav
je rebondis sur la question de notre ami
Sonia tout à l'heure qui évoquait les
questions de défense de sécurité c'est
vrai qu'il y a une inquiétude et on la
voit monter chez nos concitoyens le
sentiment que finalement l'État a baissé
la garde au moment où le monde n'a
jamais été aussi dangereux j'aimerais
que Philippe Meunier qui s'occupe des
questions de défense nous apporte une
réponse sur cette question qui est un
enjeu majeur du prochain combat
présidentiel merci à toi Luc je salue
d'ailleurs la présence de phppe Vitel
PARM nous qui siège à mes côté à la
commission de la défense et des forces
armées
oui ce dossier est extrêmement important
pour nous Français parce que il s'agit
de notre sécurité et notre liberté
liberté notamment pour nos épouses et
nos filles
avec Luc Éric nous avons travaillé sur
la convention de la défense et nous
avons retenu un certain nombre de
propositions très importante car nous
avons toute confiance dans les valeurs
morales et les qualités opérationnelles
de nos militaires c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous voulons leur donner les
moyens pour qu'ils mènent à bien leur
mission nous avons décidé de proposer
une augmentation du budget qui passera
de 1,5 % du PIB à 1,85 % du PIB d'ici la
fin du quinquena 2022 c'est un plus de
30 milliards d'euros pour nos forces
armées ça va leur permettre de maintenir
en conditions opérationnell leur
matériel ça va permettre de mettre fin à
la déflation des effectifs ça va
permettre de renouveler notre dissuasion
nucléaire dans ces deux composantes la
composante mer et la composante a
c'est extrêmement important pour notre
sécurité à terme et notre sécurité
d'aujourd'hui il s'agirait aussi de
revoter une loi de programmation
militaire dès 2017 qui sera calé sur le
quinena parce qu'il faut cesser ces ces
Herms et ces mensonges que nous
connaissons depuis la loi de
programmation militaire de 2013 cette
loi de programmation militaire sera Unat
passé avec la nation française avec nos
militaires et aussi avec nos industriels
comme ça nous saurons où nous irons les
Français pourront faire confiance et nos
armées pourront travailler en totale
sérénité pour assurer notre sécurité et
je tiens encore aujourd'hui vraiment à
saluer leurs efforts leur courage et
leur engagement pour notre
liberté merci Philippe je voudrais
évidemment l'actualité de la semaine des
derniers jours ça a été le brexit nous
avons Françoise groset député européen
qui anime la délégation du des
républicains au sein du PPE Françoise tu
nous nous éclairer nous dire un mot sur
les conséquences de ce brexit oui alors
bien sûr comme nous tous le brexit a été
quand même un choc vendredi 24 juin
quand nous avons appris les résultats de
ce
brexit même si on s'y préparait plus ou
moins nous avions toujours l'espoir que
le Royaume-Uni déciderait dans ce
référendum de rester dans l'Union
européenne alors une fois que l'on
constate cela il faut savoir réagir
réagir pour éviter les contagions réagir
pour éviter de faire la démonstration
qu'il est possible de prendre une Europe
à la carte de choisir ce que l'on veut
et et donc rester très ferme vis-à-vis
de la décision qui a été prise par le
Royaume-Uni le peuple britannique a dit
qu'il souhaitait partir et bien il part
et par contre ce que nous devons faire
c'est tout faire pour protéger notre
projet européen cette réconciliation des
Européens que nous avons tous voulu qui
a été voulu entre autres par les pères
fondateurs de l'Union européenne
réconciliation au lendemain des deux
guerres mondiales qui font qu'il fallait
qu'il fallait prévoir et construire une
union fondé sur le respect des identités
de chacun fondé sur la fidélité à nos
racines mais fondé aussi sur cette
volonté d'exercer en commun un certain
nombre de de
sujets qui sont mieux traités au niveau
communautaire au niveau européen que
chacun individuellement nous devons
protéger notre Europe mais pour la
protéger nous devons répondre à la
l'angoisse de nos concitoyens aux
questions que se posent nos concitoyens
ils ont l'impression que l'Europe ne les
protège plus ils ont
l'impression qu'elle ne les rassure plus
ils ont ils voient cette succession de
crise crise économique financière
économique sociale crise
migratoire
crise dû au terrorisme et puis ce brexit
et là nous avons des réponses très
fortes à apporter et c'est ce que les
républicains font dans le programme
qu'il vous propose sur l'Europe nous
disons nous sommes européens mais nous
voulons une autre Europe puisque cette
Europe que nous vivons aujourd'hui
démontre sa faiblesse son incapacité à
répondre à ces crises très urgentes et
bien nous apportons un certain nombre de
réponses oui nous sommes européens mais
nous voulons une Europe qui ait des
frontières qui a de véritables
frontières qui défendent ses frontières
à travers un Schengen 2 nous voulons une
Europe qui dise non parce qu'elle veut
des frontières non définitivement à la
Turquie à l'adhésion de la Turquie à
l'Union européenne il n'est pas question
d'accepter cette adhésion là
mais ce que nous voulons aussi c'est
éviter une future guerre froide
c'est-à-dire que nous voulons des
relations privilégié particulière non
seulement avec la Turquie qui est
vraiment ce ce pôle intermédiaire entre
le monde occidental et le monde oriental
mais aussi avec la Russie car nous ne
pouvons pas continuer de ne de cesser ce
dialogue avec la Russie c'est impensable
ensuite nous voulons une Europe plus
forte parce que nous défendrons la zone
euro et puis et puis enfin je termine là
ce qui est important c'est de redonner
un supplément d'âme à notre Europe de
redonner un supplément d'âme parce qu'il
faut faire comprendre à NS concitoyens
qui n'ont plus confiance dans cette
Europe que l'Europe ça n'est pas qu'un
marché unique ça n'est pas qu'une
machine à produire des normes nous ne
voulons pas de cela c'est une histoire
c'est une civilisation ce sont des
valeurs que nous partageons
tous ensemble et c'est cela que nous
voulons au républicains merci
Françoise alors ça doit vous faire
réagir micro
rouge je crois que c'est sur l'Europe
non oui bonjour mesdames et messieurs
madame gros tê beaucoup de gens depuis
vous présenteer excusez-moi Jean-Michel
Goris je suis du département de la
Vienne je suis Conseil national et je
suis également agriculteur voilà alors
vous avez effleuré un peu le une autre
Europe une vision l'Europe tout le monde
dit ça depuis le brexit le problème
c'est que personne n'a d'idée vraiment
sur ce que doit être l'Europe ou pire
chacun a une idée différente Europe
sociale Europe économique et cetera il
devrait y avoir trois articles pour qui
devrai vous servir de guide pour fixer
le mode de fonctionnement de l'Union
européenne le premier c'est l'Europe
protège les citoyens le deuxème c'est
l'Europe protège les citoyens le
troisème c'est l'Europe protège les
citoyens à partir du moment où l'Europe
est ce qu'elle devait être à l'origine
c'est-à-dire un espace de protection des
citoyens vous éviterez que lors de
référendum il soit répondu euh non à
l'Union européenne alors que pourtant
tout le monde en bénéficie y compris
dans mon milieu professionnel qui est
l'agriculture et euh il faudra j'ai
entendu des choses qui m'inquiètent sur
justement les faut-il ou non faire des
référendums je trouve que quand même la
crainte de faire des référendums
notamment sur l'Union européenne ça
instile une méfiance des politiques
vis-à-vis des citoyens qui se traduit
après par une méfiance des citoyens
vis-à-vis des politiques il ne faut pas
craindre les référendum les référendums
sont un thermomètre en aucun cas la
cause du mal merci alors c'est vrai que
parfois on peut donner l'impression de
pas avoir d'idée sur l'Europe moi j'en
connais un qui a quelques idées sur
l'Europe je sais pas s'il veut dire un
mot bon d'abord je voudrais dire que je
partage pleinement ce que notre ami
vient de dire sur le référendum nous
sommes quand même les héritiers de la
famille
Gauliste on va pas expliquer que le
problème c'est le
référendum dire que le problème c'est le
référendum c'est comme si on disait que
le problème c'était le peuple quand un
nos enfants à la fièvre on va pas jeter
le thermomètre en l'accusant d'être le
coupable donc la question pour nous de
la ligne politique sur l'Europe et sur
cette question du référendum est très
clair le référendum peut-être un moyen
pourquoi pas
nous ne voulons ni le faire à toutes
condition ni refuser à tout
prix deuxème remarque sur sur
l'Europe Schengen est
mort je l'avais dit lors du meeting de
Villepinte Alain Gérard s'en souvienent
très certainement on avait parlé de
cette question on était tous d'accord
là-dessus depuis Madame Merkel a enterré
Dublin ça fait 2 ans qu'il y a plus
rien on a quand même le droit nous qui
sommes européens de dire
réveillez-vous qu'est-ce qui vous
empêche de faire un Schengen 2 qui doit
gérer la politique migratoire de
l'Europe l'Europe peut-il être le seul
continent qui n'ait pas le droit des
frontières et qui garde les frontières
de l'Europe nous ne voulons pas que ça
soit un commissaire européen qui a la
responsabilité de Frontex nous voulons
un euroengen avec les ministres de
l'Intérieur qui Élise un président
stable bon deuxièmement je l'ai dit
notamment à Philippe Meier et un certain
nombre d'entre nous qui ont le droit
d'être
souverainiste c'est pas une maladie
honteuse qui a deux lignes rouges deux
lignes rouges pour nous je les assume il
n'est pas question que les républicains
renoncent à l'idéal européen il n'en est
pas question nous sommes les héritiers
de ceux qui ont batti l'Europe c'était
une initiative française car je rappelle
qu'à l'idée de l'Europe ce sont les
Français deuxè ligne rouge je je préfère
le dire très simplement même si on est
en désaccord avec Madame Merkel même si
on est agacé par les Allemands nous
n'accepterons jamais que l'on remette en
cause la réconciliation franco-allemande
et l'amitié franco-allemande parce que
ça serait trop
grave à partir de ce
moment-là qu'est-ce qu'on veut comme
changement moi qui a toujours été pour
l'Alliance atlantique qui a voulu que la
France revienne dans le commandement
intégré j'avais à l'époque parler
beaucoup avec un ministre des Affaires
étrangères excellent au demeurant
n'est-ce pas Alain mais je n'accepte pas
je dis bien je n'accepte pas la volonté
récente des
Américains d'imposer un impérialisme sur
la finance mondial sur les banques
mondiales sur le droit mondial ou sur le
commerce mondial et je dis le FMI n'a
rien à faire au cœur de la zone euro
rien et
enfin il me semble et ça nous rassemble
tous qu'on doit clairement dire après le
drame du
brexit que l'élargissement c'est fini en
tout cas tant qu'on s'est pas doté
d'institution digne de ce nom he pierre
et que par ailleurs c'est très clair
dans notre esprit nous l'avions dit il y
a bien longtemps nous ne voulons pas de
la Turquie au sein de l'Union européenne
ni maintenant ni demain et je termine
par
là mais nous ne voulons pas etadine le
sait nous ne voulons pas davantage d'une
invraisemblable nouvelle guerre froide
avec les Russes parce que le destin du
continent européen c'est de travailler
main dans la main avec les Russes quel
que soit par ailleurs les désaccords que
l'on peut avoir avec Monsieur
Poutine merci pendant que Hervé Mariton
s'installe à la tribune je vais saluer
la présence d'Isabelle Debray nos
parlementaires qui nous ont rejoint
Isabelle Debré Marie-Christine dalallos
marine Brunier philippe Juvin j'ai
oublié de citer Yve Fromion notre
président du groupe à l'Assemblée
nationale Christian
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Jacob chers conseillers
nationaux cher président des
républicains Nicolas
Sarkozi c'est un honneur ce matin pour
nous tous saler pour moi d'intervenir et
de discuter ensemble du
projet c'est un bonheur de par les
projets quand comme beaucoup d'entre
nous nous mettons les idées au cœur de
notre
engagement j'ai eu l'honneur pendant une
paire d'année de m'occuper du projet
j'ai eu le bonheur Nicolas Éric
Isabelle de participer à beaucoup des
conventions qui ont permis ces derniers
mois d'échanger entre
nous nous avons de défis collectifs pour
nous républicain et pour la France
d'abord bien sûr gagner l'élection
présidentielle mais et c'est
l'essentiel réussir
l'alternance
vous le
savez je suis candidat au
primairire je ne suis pas sûr d'être élu
mais je suis sûr que des idées fortes
franches audacieuses innovantes sont
indispensable à l'avenir de la France et
à la réussite de l'alternance et pour
avoir fait mesurer la vie des Français
ces mesures sont nécessaires et
soutenues l'impôt universel et
proportionnel rassemble soutien de 70 %
de nos sympathisants cher Serge le droit
du sang le soutien de 61 % et la
majorité est favorable à l'abrogation de
la loi su alors il y a un danger
aujourd'hui les amis c'est qu'à force
que la gauche dise que nous irions trop
loin à force qu'une bonne part de la
presse dise aussi que nous serions trop
durs dans nos mesures le danger est au
contraire de ne pas être assez fort de
ne pas être assez ferme de ne pas être
assez vigoureux originaux innovants dans
notre projet nous ne voulons pas je ne
veux pas de demi-mesure ni à droite ni à
gauche et voyez les malheurs du
gouvernement enfermés dans le projet
lcomerie qui est tout entier torturé par
cette logique des demi-mesures les
demi-mesures vous le savez c'est assez
pour se faire des adversaires pas assez
pour éveiller des alliés soulever
l'optimisme l'ous
alors oui nous souhaitons je souhaite
retrouver l'enthousiasme l'optimisme
pour l'avenir de notre pays oui soyons
audacieux et
innovants comme vous j'ai reçu hier soir
les 400 pages du projet qui nous est
présenté ce matin résultat des débats
des conventions il y a dans ce document
des choses intéressantes mais je vous le
dis c'est en tout cas mon opinion et je
l'exprime en toute franchise sur des
sujets essentiels le compte n'y est pas
sur
l'identité on ne peut pas tourner autour
du sujet et poser la question du droit
du sang sans y répondre on ne peut pas
vouloir corriger le droit du sol de
manière si modeste et si pilanimme je
suis pour le droit du sang comme
principe directeur de la nationalité je
l'assume pour la famille on ne peut pas
on ne doit pas se contenter de répondre
rétablissement des prestations
familiales il se joue autour de
laffiliation d'un père et mais des
choses beaucoup plus
essentielles pour les retraites
excuse-moi Nicolas mais tu connais ma
franchise peut-être parfois mon
insolence mais je pense que les mesures
que tu proposes ne sont pas suffisantes
et qu'il faut assumer une réforme
beaucoup plus fondamentale du système
vers une retraite par point assumer un
étage de capitalisation c'est
indispensable et ça ne fait pas de nous
des libéraux sectaires doctrinaires
ultra et ne comprenons pas pas les
enjeux du monde au contraire le
capitalisme français a besoin de
capitaux notre économie a besoin de
capitaux et l'absence de capitalisation
dans les retraites est une faute majeure
sur un sujet très technique et important
la dépendance j'ai regardé ce qui était
proposé de recourir et de rester dans la
logique de l'assurance maladie depuis
des années que nous disons cela nous
n'avons rien fait d'autres n'ont rien
fait et cette carence est tragique j'ai
proposé le lundi de Pentecôte c'était le
moment de s'exprimer là-dessus une
proposition beaucoup plus audacieuse
beaucoup plus originale avec un
engagement des assurances privées qui
peuvent répondre aux formes les plus
légères de l'assurance bref je l'assume
je le dis en responsabilité je ne dis
pas de guêé de cœur parce que je suis
ami et je trouve que beaucoup de
réflexions apporté ces derniers mois
étaient très fortes et très heureuses
mais globalement contte tenu de ce
qu'est le projet aujourd'hui je dis non
à ce projet en l'état parce qu'ensemble
les amis nous avons le devoir et nous
avons la capacité tous rassemblés ici
d'être beaucoup plus puissant nous ne
devons pas nous n'avons d'ailleurs pas
le droit d'avoir peur de la liberté pour
des jeunes pour lesquels seul une
véritable autonomie de l'éducation et la
clé de l'amélioration d'un système si
dégradé ces dernières années et pas des
corrections à la marge il s'agit pas de
déplacer un curseur il s'agit de choisir
franchement quoi que dise la gauche quoi
que dise la presse le principe de
liberté et d'autonomie pour les actifs
je vous le redis l'impôt universel est
proportionnel et la seule réponse
moderne qu'on puisse apporter quand le
gouvernement nous amuse avec ce projet
funeste de la retenue à la source sur
lequelle pour le coup je dis aussi que
nous devons dire clairement dès
aujourd'hui que nous n'en voulons pas et
que nous n'en voudrons pas nous ne
devons pas avoir peur du monde et ce
qu'a dit Françoise grosette était très
heureux à entendre et c'est important
oui nous voulons refonder l'Europe je
propose que nous ayons au bon moment et
sur le bon projet un référendum européen
pour une Europe de liberté nous avons
besoin de l'Europe l'Europe a besoin de
nous l'Europe c'est nous nous n'y sommes
pas étrangers je ne suis pas
eurosceptique parce que je me bats pour
la France il faut répondre les amis aux
exigences que posent les Français sur
l'avenir de notre niveau de vie l'avenir
de notre mode de vie oui il faut donner
à la France toute la force dans la
compétition armée du monde j'assume une
compétition armée Luc parce que si on
n'est pas armé on se fait bouffer mais
si on n'assume pas la compétition du
monde en le disant très fort et très
ferme alors nous serons marginalisés et
nous serons défit aussi chers amis il y
a aujourd'hui un vote je vous propose de
voter contre ce projet car c'est sur des
points essentiels un projet de
demi-mesure je vous le dis je l'assume
je ne je ne méprise pas le travail qui a
été réalisé mais quand comme moi et et
quelques autres nous pensons que le
compte n est pas je crois qu'il vaut
mieux le dire très explicitement et en
rendre compte devant nos amis plutôt que
de garder cela en dedans et en même
temps j'ai de l'espoir parce que je
pense que dans les mois qui viennent le
débat va se poursuivre il y a bien sûr
le débat des primaires et je souhaite
que les mois qui viennent soient des
mois d'espoir d'espoir pour gagner pour
réussir l'alternance tous ensemble
militants élus parlementaires
responsablebl du parti candidat à la
primaire
en tout cas pour ce qui me concerne avec
celles et ceux qui m'accompagnent dans
cet effort porter oui un projet de
liberté et de valeur pourtant il est
important de transmettre un socle de
libérer l'action sans céder jamais au
demi-mesure car les Français ne nous le
pardonneraient pas pour retrouver pour
mobiliser la France oui chaque jour qui
vient avec un projet plus puissant c'est
ma conviction c'est mon engagement dans
un travail dans lequel Nicolas je prends
à la fois ma responsabilité personnelle
et mon engagement collectif aucun
d'entre nous ne ménage sa peine pour
porter ses efforts avançons rendons ce
projet plus dense plus convainquant plus
efficace demain pour réussir
l'alternance car je suis convaincu avec
toutes celles et tous ceux qui sont
réunis aujourd'hui ici qu'ensemble oui
ensemble en y mettant la volonté
l'audace le courage ensemble nous
gagnerons pour que vive républain et que
vive la
france
merci comme je l'ai dit ce matin une
famille politique moderne on s'écoute on
présente ses idées vous décidez à la fin
on votera tout à l'heure Nicolas
S je voudrais remercier HERV de sa prise
de parole parce que c'est toujours utile
il rappelit lui-même qu'il avait été en
charge du projet malheureusement dans
les de années il y avait pas eu un seul
conseil nation qui a été réuni pour
débattre du projet à l'époque je
n'aurais pas eu la possibilité de dire
ça si j'ai voulu le Conseil national
c'est justement pour que ça se passe pas
comme avant et justement pour que
quelqu'un qui n'est pas d'accord puisse
le dire deuxièmement je voudrais faire
deux remarques très brèves la
première on ne m'appelle jamais au
courage et à l'authenticité enfin
que les choses soient claires entre
nous je n'accepterai pas de présider une
famille politique qui renoncerait à
cette tradition républicaine française
du droit du sang et du droit du sol je
le dis comme je le
pense et il faut que ça soit clair entre
nous et la proposition que nous faisons
faut-il ne pas l'avoir lu pour la
trouver demi-mesure
elle consiste à transformer le droit du
sol en une prison tion de nationalité
non pas en une automaticité de la
nationalité c'està-dire qu'un enfant qui
naî sur le sol de la République
française et présumé français sauf si
ses parents sont en situation illégale
au moment où ils n sauf si ses parents
ont un cier judiciaire car dans ce
cas-là lui comme ses enfants nous
n'accepterons pas qu'il est la
nationalité française présenter cela
comme une
demiesure
absolu absolu je le dis avec amitié
naturellement la deuxième
remarque sur les retraites je connais
par cœur la théorie elle était déjà
celle d'Alain Madelin quand il s'est
présenté aux élections présidentielles
au premier tour face à Jacques Chirac
avec 3 % des suffrages à l'arrivée ce
qui montre que le simple fait de
s'afficher libéral n'est me semble-t-il
pas le passeport absolu pour rassembler
une majorité de Français je rappelle que
pour gagner au 2è tour il faut 21
millions de Français donc il faut ouvrir
notre esprit mais sur la réforme des
retraites et je parle sous le contrôle
de Gérard quand avec François Fillon et
Monsieur ver qui est ici mon ami qui a
été mon ministre et qui a porté cette
réforme des retraites pas un syndicat
n'a voté avec nous on a fait passer les
cotisations la date de départ à la
retraite de 60 à 62 ans ce qui fait
qu'avec le calcul des trimestres la
retraite on peut la prendre avec sa
pension pleine à 67 ans c'était la
réforme la plus difficile de toute
l'Europe et la Cour des comptes a rendu
et la Cour des comptes a rendu un
rapport dans lequel il indique elle
indique que le régime d'assurance
vieillesse est aujourd'hui à l'équilibre
cher RV dans le projet que tu trouves
FAD nous annonçons 63 ans pour 200 20 64
ans pour 2025 ce qui veut dire qu'avec
les trimestres on pourra partir avec sa
retraite pleine en 2025 à 69 ans qui ici
va m'expliquer que c'est de la
demi-mesure donc moi je te remercie
parce que j'aime le débat je crois dans
le débat tu as parfaitement raison de
dire ce que tu penses tu es le bienvenu
de sur croix j'apprécie que toi tu es
participé à des conventions je t'en
remercie et si tu as dit ce que tu as
dit ça fait vivre le mouvement et moi ça
me donne le plaisir de te répondre et ça
vraiment
merci merci Nicolas éic notre secrétaire
général voulait compléter répondre sur
le projet je voudais dire aussi en
complément de ce que dit Nicolas c'est
toujours plus simple HERV de faire un
projet tout seul que de le faire sur un
plan collectif c'est plus compliqué
aujourd'hui de réunir pendant 15 mois
des gens d'écouter les militant et de
faire un travail qui n'est pas un
travail de demi-mesure puisque cette
mesure tu l'as compris nous a un peu
irrité dans tes propos c'est un projet
de pleine mesure c'est un projet
d'impact et c'est pas un concours
l'épine un projet politique on doit
répondre aux questions que se posent les
Français les militants lorsqu'on est en
républicain les Français bien entendu et
y apporter des solutions et les
solutions qu'on apporte ce sont des
solutions pour redresser le le pays il y
a pas de demi-mesure dans le domaine des
retraites mais Nicolas l'a évoqué la
vraie question c'est d'affronter l'âge
de la retraite c'est pas de se poser la
question il y aura toujours un
complément par capitalisation mais je
crois pas que tu veuilles mettre fin au
régime par répartition c'est pas ce que
tu as dit et je ne crois pas que tu le
veuille donc on ne doit pas mettre fin à
ce régime par répartition et pour
équilibrer le régime par répartition il
faut évidemment se poser la question de
la durée de cotisation mais surtout la
question de l'âge et c'est ça qui est
difficile aujourd'hui à affronter et les
retraites par point c'est pas une
solution en termes financiers c'est une
solution d'adaptation et de cohérence
des différents régimes et on y répond
puisqu'on a dit que on mettra fin aux
différences définitivement entre les
régimes publics et les régimes privés
c'est vrai aussi sur la famille nous ne
parlons pas de la famille uniquement en
indiquant que nous parlons des
allocations familiales ou d'une vision
économique de la famille nous mettons
des lignes rouges totales nous parlons
par exemple de la GPA qui est une
horreur une ignominie qui est un
commerce du ventre des femmes et nous le
disons avec fermeté et puis lorsqu'on
parle de dépendance on évoque tout cela
et d'identité aussi donc moi je suis je
suis très attaché estce que le projet
des républicains il aille très vite il
aille très loin il aille très fort mais
le débat il est là pour ça et le débat
il va se poursuivre c'est une brique
essentielle dans ce débat il pouvait pas
y avoir un parti politique aussi fort
que le N autre redressé par Nicolas en
quelques dizaines de mois et en même
temps avoir un parti qui n'est pas de
projet ce projet c'est un vrai projet
c'est un projet lourd c'est un projet
qui est capable de redresser le pays
puis après il y aura un débat et puis
Infiné dans 10 mois il y aura un projet
présidentiel et celui-là on le portera
tous merci
RIC alors chers amis on a eu beaucoup de
questions là jusqu'à présent sur
l'orégalien sur la justice sur les
questions de sécurité sur l'Europe je
vais peut-être demander à Pierre
Lelouche de nous dire un mot sur les
questions d'affaires étrangères avec ce
monde toujours plus turbulent et il sera
complété par Alain Joyandet qui nous
dira un mot sur la fruc pierre c'est à
toi merci beaucoup je voudrais dire
d'abord que j'ai énormément de plaisir
à accompagner le président du mouvement
dans nos déplacements à l'étrangers sur
les questions
internationales c'est j'ai été très fier
d'être son ministre
et je suis et je suis très heureux de
travailler avec lui sur ces questions
sur lesquelles il a une une très grande
expérience la la politique
internationale ce qui se passe dans le
monde est tellement lourd et tellement
complexe et dangereux que ça va impacter
nécessairement notre campagne
présidentielle ça a déjà commencé avec
le brexit mais il y a beaucoup d'autres
volets qui vont percuter notre
campagne le premier d're
x je je va citer quatre ou CIN choses
lourdes qui arrivent dans lequel la
France va devoir tracer son chemin il
faudra des des chefs d'État
expérimentés lucides capable de faire ça
le le premier de ces défis sera celui de
la
démographie depuis les années 60
l'Afrique a déjà doublé de population
elle va redoubler de population le
résultat c'est l'an dernier en 2015 il
est rentré en Europe 1,8 million de
personnes près de 2 millions de
personnes sont entrées en Europe sans
contrôle cette situation malheureusement
va continuer donc la démographie sera
une un défi permanent pour nous dans les
années qui viennent elle appellera un
changement considérable de politique de
développement elle
appellera une vraie stratégie de
contrôle des naissances de l'autre côté
de la Méditerranée mais je pense que
Alain Joyandet va en dire un mot tout à
l'heure la deuxième chose que je
voudrais vous dire qui est ressorti de
notre convention du 15 juin dernier qui
était d'ailleurs une très bonne
convention c'est la chose suivante et
c'est très important il faut
comprendre s'il vous plaît continue
continue
pierre est-ce que ceux qui donnent des
interviews peuvent sortir de la salle
parce qu'il y en a qui souhaitent
écouter les
intervenants merci Pierre à toi c'est
gentil parce que j'allais je crois vous
dire quelque chose d'important dans
l'histoire de l'Europe
depuis au moins un
siècle en tout cas depuis la fin de la
première guerre mondiale nous les
Européens on a pris l'habitude de
considérer que le proche- Orient c'était
loin et qu'on y exportait nos guerres on
a dépessé l'Empire ottoman on a fabriqué
des états il faut savoir qu'on a
fabriqué par exemple la Syrie le Liban
l'Irak avec nos amis anglais on a
exporté la guerre ce qui est en train de
nous arriver aujourd'hui mesdames et
messieurs mes chers amis monsieur le
Président c'est que le proche orient
s'invite chez nous et que nous importons
la guerre nous importons les résultats
de la guerre nous importons les migrants
nous importons les
terroristes c'est ça la situation de
l'Europe dans les années qui viennent et
c'est une situation lourde il va falloir
entièrement repenser notre politique de
terrorisme et de défense et nous y
travaillons avec Philippe avec
georgeisusion tout à l'heure présente
cette semaines même les conclusions de
notre commission d'enquête à l'Assemblée
sur ces sujets il y aura beaucoup à y
ajouter du côté des républicains donc ça
c'est
fondamental il faudra aussi qu'on
repense notre politique étrangère au
prochorient il faut pas que la France
soit dans un camp contre l'autre comme
le fait Monsieur Hollande en
bourmolettiste suiviste des Américains
marié avec un camp contre l'autre nous
avons vocation à ne pas entrer dans la
guerre entre les Sunnites et les chiites
mais au contraire à tracer une ligne de
tion je pense notamment au Liban Luc me
dit qu'il faut que j'arrête donc
j'arrête il y avait quelques autres
sujets légers par exemple la Chine
qu'est-ce qu'on fait sur le statut
d'économie de la Chine commentéconomie
de marché qu' réclame comment est-ce
qu'on gère et je remercie Nicolas d'y
avoir fait allusion un sujet sur lequel
je travaille énormément c'est cet
impérium américain qui utilise le droit
les bons sentiments la lutte contre la
corruption contre le climat et cetera
pour imposer à nos sociétés françaises
et européennes des amendes extravagantes
avec des conséquences économiques
redoutables pensez à la BNP pensez à
Alstom Airbus ou même encore il y a 2
jours Volkswagen qui a pris une prune à
16 milliards d'euros et c'est pas fini
c'est très bon pour l'industrie
automobile américaine je pourrais
continuer comme ça mais Luc me demande
de terminer je vais peut-être te dire
une petite réflexion Luc la prochaine
fois je Seris candidat au primaire moi
aussi comme ça j'aur un peu plus de
temps de
parole merci Pierre Alain Joyandet pour
compléter sur
l'Afrique ça marche pas si oui merci de
quelques minutes pour parler d'un petit
sujet qui est celui de
l'Afrique pour notre nouvelle politique
étrangère le président Sarkozi a proposé
ses quatre priorités dans ces quatre
priorités il y en a une c'est l'Afrique
et nous avons beaucoup travaillé sur ce
sujet avec avec Pierre et notamment avec
la diaspora africaine à Paris nos
ambassadeurs africains à Paris nos
ambassadeurs français et nous avons
sorti trois grandes directions pour
l'avenir une qui consiste cher Nicolas à
retrouver un leadership en Europe pour
convaincre nos partenaires européens
d'un grand projet de développement pour
le continent africain qui soit pas
imposé aux africains mais qui soit
proposé aux africains est mise en œuvre
avec eux si l'Afrique ne se développe
pas dans les 20 ans qui viennent
l'Europe aura de très grands soucis 2
milliards d'habitants en 2050 en Afrique
60 % de cette population aura moins de
26 ans assez peu de monde en parle c'est
pourtant à notre avis au Républicain
l'enjeu majeur pour l'avenir du monde
d'ici à 2050 et ça sera sans doute un
des grands enjeux je de la politique
étrangère de la France et de l'Europe
évidemment puisque nous ne ferons pas
tout seul nous voulons essayer de
transmettre et c'est le premier pilier
de notre proposition petit à petit les
missions régaliennes que nous assumons à
la place des africains aux Africains le
deuxième pilier que nous proposons c'est
de renforcer nos liens culturels avec
notamment la proposition d'un visa
francophone un Erasmus nous voulons
aussi proposer pour Paris une maison de
l'Afrique qui serait le symbole de cette
grande volonté de la France pour le
continent africain enfin nous voulons
que l'Agence française de développement
soit vraiment le bras séculier du
gouvernement français avec un directeur
nommé par le Président de la République
vous connaissez l'attachement de notre
président des républicains à ce que un
certain nombre de grands fonctionnaires
de la France soit véritablement mise en
mise en place par le nouveau président
de la République pour assumer le projet
du président et du gouvernement voilà
quelques grandes directions sur
lesquelles nous sommes allés nous allons
continuer à travailler évidemment avec
les Africains qui nous ont beaucoup
expliqué en citant Nelson Mandela qu'un
projet fait pour eux mais sans eux
serait un projet contre eux donc nous
travaillons avec eux nous leur redisons
évidemment toute notre attachement à ce
continent africain et aux Africains
parce que une Afrique qui se développe
et qui donne du travail à sa jeunesse et
bien c'est une Europe en paix et c'est
une France qui n'aura pas à faire face à
des flux d'immigration qui serait
incontrôlé merci de votre attention
merci
al je salue la présence de Jean-François
Copé et j'appelle Nadine Morano à venir
s'exprimer sur
[Applaudissements]
scène
attends
jealler allez
allez on enchane bien pendant que nos
amis s'installent monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les les
parlementaires Mesdames et Messieurs les
élus chers conseillers nationaux venus
de partout de France de nos fédérations
je voudrais vous dire qu'aujourd'hui la
situation est extrêmement grave et que
nous avons un devoir c'est de réussir
dans 10 mois l'alternance d'espérance
mais de fermeté qu'attend aujourd'hui
nos concitoyens alors je vous le dis ce
projet je le voterai par respect pour le
travail qui a été
mené par l'ensemble des militants par
les experts par aussiip dirigeante de
notre famille politique nous sommes le
premier parti politique de France nous
sommes celui sans doute qui incarnons
une vraie crédibilité et quel parti
aurait une existence s'il n'avait pas un
projet formulé un socle formulé qui
après n'engage pas obligatoirement sur
toutes les propositions les candidats à
la primaire mais qui au moins est la
vitrine du travail que nous avons pu
réaliser ensemble alors je vous le
disais la situation est grave et nous
allons avoir cette primaire primaire qui
ne doit pas être primaire parce que nous
avons sans doute des divergences de vue
nous avons besoin de différents
candidats essayons de nous respecter les
uns les autres et essayons d'avoir une
divergence à la fois d'idée de parcours
de personnalité pour qu'au moins cette
primaire qui existe intéresse les
Français d'ailleurs je constate que
c'est cette primaire intéresse plus les
républicains puisque nous ferons une
primaire entre nous j'entends nos
partenaires centr tristes les autres
sonent tristes ce qui ne sont pas avec
nous nous dire que le projet ne les
engage pas qu'il ne participeront pas à
la primaire mais que pour beaucoup
d'entre eux certains iront voter à cette
primaire j'entends beaucoup de
mobilisation quand il s'agit d'avoir des
postes pour les élections législatives
ou pour figurer sur les listes
régionales j'entends moins de
mobilisation à dire qu'ensemble nous
allons sauver la France alors chers amis
en
France la situation est tellement grave
que les barbares décapitent un chef
d'entreprise en France les barbares
abattent nos enfants en plein spectacle
des clients insouciant sur les terrasses
des cafés en France les barbares
assassinent un policier et sa compagne
chez eux devant le regard de leurs
enfants en France la place de la
République est devenue un immense Jurin
noir où la nuit debout d'agitateur est
devenu un cauchemar pour les riverins
les casseurs redoublent de violence les
manifestations ne sont pas contenues les
lois ne sont plus respectées l'autorité
de l'État est bafouée au quotidien en
France le chômage explose et notre
croissance est en berne mais pour
François Hollande président actuel de la
France ça va mieux mes chers amis nous
avons 10 mois à subir un chef d'État qui
se complet dans le dénis et
l'impuissance son levier d'action reste
en permanence la dépense publique à
croire qu'avec ses promesses intenables
de baisse d'impôt après les avoir
tugmenté il se délecte dans la posture
d'un simple Père Noël après celle de
père
foitard nous avons 10 mois pour nous
préparer à une alternance porteuse
d'espoir mais attention les Français
comme les Anglais et les autres peuples
européens sont excédés par des
dirigeants incapables de leur apporter
la protection et la prospérité qu'ils
attendent leur jugement sera singlant il
y a fort à parié qu'avec le même
référendum en France les Français
auraient voté comme les Britanniques
sortons du politiquement correct qui ne
plaît qu'à la classe médiatico-politique
caénarque et à tous ceux qui veulent
prendre le peuple en otage par leur
bienpensance si lointaines du bon sens
et des préoccupations des Français
croyez-vous qu'il soit digne de la
France de se plier à une politique de
quotas de migrant qui au final vient
grossir la jungle de Calais participe au
développement des bidonvilles sur notre
territoire et que dire de la perspective
d'un camp de migrants à Paris à Paris
annoncé par le maire de Paris Paris
capitale de de la France vitrine de
notre pays cette décision
irresponsable impacte toute la France
elle démontre l'impuissance du
gouvernement à handiguer la vague
migratoire de masse que nous subissons
l'alternance devrait être porteuse
d'espoir je vous l'ai dis mais ferme je
dis non à l'implantation d'un camp de
réfugiés au cœur de
Paris notre famille
politique doit avoir une position claire
sur cette question ne nous y trompons
pas les Français ont toujours été un
peuple accueillant mais il ne supporent
plus que soit bafoué sa culture son
identité son mode de vie ses lois
comment accueillir dignement chez nous
quand on détruit notre maison de
l'intérieur alors que certains ont une
drôle de lecture de la laïcité en
voulant interdire les crèches dans les
lieux public je vous le dis les Français
croyants ou non croyants sont attachés
au racine chrétienne de la France et à
son fabuleux patrimoine dans notre
pays je propose d'inscrire à l'article 1
de notre Constitution la France a des
racines chrétiennes nous devons
préserver notre histoire si nous voulons
garantir le bon fonctionnement de notre
République laïque vivre en France c'est
la respecter les comportement
communautarisme ne sont plus tolérables
trop facile d'accepter la France pour
les aides sociales et la mépriser quand
il faut la
[Applaudissements]
respecter je propose de durcir la loi
que nous avons adopté sur l'interdiction
du port du voile intégral en cas de
récidive je vous le dis en cas de
récidive nous n'avons pas à hésiter il
faudra suspendre les droits civies et
les droits sociaux de ce qui ne veulent
pas se plier à notre culture on ne peut
pas porter le voile intégral et aller
chercher les allocation familiale ou la
PL et à un moment il faut
[Applaudissements]
choisir on ne peut pas accepter des
mosquées dans lesquelles on laisse des
imams qui ne parlent pas français sauf
quand ça les arrange pour manipuler nos
jeunes voyez l'imam de Brest dont le
président de la République croyait que
la mosquée était fermée et bien non
cette mosquée dans laquelle on apprend
aux enfants que la musique c'est le
diable dans cette mosquée comme dans
beaucoup d'autres ces mosquées
salafistes qu'on a identifié mais qui ne
sont toujours pas fermés où on prêche la
soumission de la femme sur le territoire
national il faudra modifier nos lois on
ne peut pas accepter la soumission de la
femme en France
[Applaudissements]
alors je vous le dis je suis très triste
de ce qui s'est passé au Royaume-Uni je
crois profondément à l'Europe comme
Françoise grostet je suis laorine je
viens une région à trois frontières où
il y a énormément de cimetières
militaires dont celui d'Andy près de
chez moi 36000 soldats allemands qui
sont couchés en dessous l'équivalent de
la ville de toule et toute la communauté
de communes aux alentours
la construction de l'Europe avait de
vrais architectes la réconciliation
allemande est notre bien le plus
précieux la construction européenne a
été gage de paix pendant 70 ans
j'appartiens à la première génération
qui n'a pas connu la guerre je ne veux
pas que mes enfants la connaissent ni
mes petits enfants nous devons protéger
cette Europe mais pour protéger cette
Europe nous devons aussi arrêter cette
Commission européenne qui se croit toute
puissante alors qu'elle n'a pas la légi
démocratique et qui impose des quotas de
migrants au
peuple nous devons protéger nos
frontières extérieures tout comme nous
devons protéger l'espace Schengen qui
est une vraie avancée et dans ma région
on en sait quelque chose parce que nous
n'avons plus ces kilomètres de bouchon à
la frontière pour pouvoir aller
travailler les transfrontaliers qui sont
à peu près 60000 à aller travailler par
jour au Luxembourg le savent bien j'en
termine par dire
que les frontières extérieures
évidemment il faut les protéger c'est
essentiel mais ça n'est pas suffisant il
faut arrêter de faire prendre des vessis
pour des lanternes à nos compatriotes ce
qu'a dit Alain Joyandet est tout à fait
exact il faudra que l'Europe protège
chez frontières qu'elle réforme l'espace
Schengen mais qu'elle est une vraie
politique de c-éveloppement avec
l'Afrique je soutiens la fondation de
Jean-Louis borlot qui propose
l'électrification du continent africain
qui nous demanderait des efforts de 4
milliards et demi d'euros par an alors
alors que 25 % seulement du continent
africain est électrifié aujourd'hui
c'est le seul gage du développement qui
permettra d'arrêter la crise migratoire
de masse que nous vivons et notre
engagement à la fois sur la scène
politique diplomatique et militaire en
Syrie comme en Libye pour arrêter cette
vague migratoire de masse alors ma
conclusion sera de vous dire que cette
primaire devrait être un bel exercice
enfin je l'espère mais que l'objectif le
seul que nous devons avoir en tête c'est
de l'élection présidentielle nous ne
devons pas
céder à nos
sentiments à nos amitiés mais pensez que
la personnalité qui se dégagera des
primaires doit être la meilleure pour
pouvoir sauver la France je vous le dis
parce que nous en sommes là sauver la
France et sauver l'Europe alors cette
échéance que nous devons gagner doit
nous permettre d'avoir un vote pour et
pas avoir un vote contre comme nous en
permanence il nous faut un vote pour un
vote d'adhésion pour que le soir de
l'élection présidentielle nous ayons
place de la République des drapeaux
français et seulement des drapeaux
français pour que
chacun s'identifie à la France aime la
France le démontre a vers son destin et
son avenir parce que la France le mérite
et nous devons tous ensemble donner cet
amour de la France parce que la France
est une grande puissance merci
ci